hello everyone welcome to my video
series of mall bioexplained in three
minutes where i explain the concept of
molecular biology in less than three
minutes or so if you haven't yet
subscribed to that channel
hit that subscribe button today's
installment we'll talk about reverse
transcriptase pcr
and this kind of pcr converts
mrna into cdna with the help of reverse
transcriptase enzyme
so with the help of reverse
transcriptase enzyme you can see
mrna is converted into a complementary
dna
this cdna can be utilized for various
applications for example if you are
making a cdna library this is the first
step
in terms of gene expression analysis
cdna preparation is the first step
so let's learn how this process is done
and what is the scientific basis behind
it
but let me tell you this kind of process
was formulated
after knowing that several virus can
perform reverse transcription reaction
such as the hiv virus
hiv virus has reversed transcriptase
enzyme which converts the viral mrna
into cdna and looking at this biological
phenomena
scientists designed this qpcr this
particular
rtpcr strategy now let us look at a mrna
this particular mrna has a five prime
cap and a three prime polyadenylated
tail
so the first step of this reverse
transcriptase pcr
is to form a primer and generally the
primer
that is used in this kind of reaction is
a oligodt primer
a stretch of t so
reverse transcriptase enzyme can start
synthesizing the cdna strand
if you have this oligo dt primer but in
reality
this particular reaction is little bit
more complex
so instead of using only oligo tt
scientists prefer to use
a combination of oligo tt and random
hexamark primers
now from the oligodt let's say this
particular reverse transcriptase starts
is
its journey and wherever there is random
hexamar it can start a fresh
set of elongation from that point
now processivity of reverse
transcriptase is low
and that is why using a combination of
hexamr and
dt gives good yield
so let's compare normal pcr with the
reverse transcriptase pcr when it is
normal pcr template is dna
but in case of reverse transcriptase pcr
mrna act as a template
in normal pcr forward and reverse primer
cocktail is used
while in the reverse transcriptase pcr
oligodt and random hexamr primer is used
dntp is used in both of these reactions
in normal pcr that polymerase is used
whereas in reverse transcriptase pcr
reverse
transcriptase enzyme is used and
adequate buffer magnesium chloride these
kind of
components are used in both these cases
and the program that is used to generate
or use to amplify the products they are
also different
in normal pcr the tag polymerase works
in 72 degree centigrade
while reverse transcriptase at least the
newer version of
reverse transcriptase works at 50 degree
centigrade
and the programs are also very different
and let us try to understand what
exactly happens
during these cycles in the thermal
cycler
so first step is the incubation at 60
degree centigrade for 5 minutes
where the secondary structures of the
rna is resolved
and a linearized rna is formed then a
stage
where four degree centigrade is reached
then
several primers such as the oligo dt
and the hexamer primer can anneal to
this
rna later on at 50 degree centigrade
temperature
the reverse transcriptase can recruit it
can be recruited and it can start
polymerizing and synthesizing the cdna
strand
after it has done its job it can be
heat inactivated at 80 degree centigrade
and that is how we
obtain c dna from the
rt pcr reaction let me tell you rt pcr
reaction
is often confused with real-time
quantitative pcr
but real-time quantitative pcr and
reverse transcriptase pcr
are two different thing but let me tell
you that
before quantitative pcr you have to
perform reverse transcriptase pcr to
generate the cdna altogether
if you want to learn more about rt qpcr
or real-time quantitative pcr you can
click on the
video in the i button so
if you like this video give it a big
thumbs up you can share me
you can uh support me via patreon you
can also
pay me via uh other methods my qr
the code is given here if you're an
indian viewer you can support me
by that if you like this video give it a
big thumbs up don't forget to like share
and subscribe you can also take my
academy course by using my code ab10 you
can get a 10 discount thank you